This is FRESH AIR I'm Terry Gross This week we're featuring some of our favorite interviews
of the Year Later on this edition we'll hear from Jeffrey Tambor the star of transparent.
Up first my interview with Gloria Steinem recorded in
October Steinem has been a leader and symbol of the women's movement since the one nine hundred
seventy
S. and continues to speak out at the age of eighty
one she co-founded Ms Magazine in one thousand nine hundred two and remained one of its editors
for fifteen
years. She's written about political social and economic barriers to women's
rights and has also written about her own life and the personal obstacles. She's had to
overcome and how they represent obstacles many women face her latest
book My Life on the road was published in the fall.
She estimates that she spent at least half of her time on the road for more than four
decades. She's traveled with a purpose to raise awareness of women's
issues and organize women in the U.S. and around the world as we'll hear
later in the interview she kind of grew up on the road.
Gloria Steinem Welcome back to FRESH
AIR I want you to start by reading the dedication of your new book.
This book is dedicated to Dr John Sharp of London who
in one nine hundred fifty seven a decade before physicians in England could
legally perform an abortion
for any reason other than the health of the woman took the
considerable risk of referring for an abortion twenty two year old American
on her way to
India knowing only that she had broken an engagement at home to seek
an unknown fate. He
said You must promise me two things first you will not tell anyone
my name.
Second you will do what you want to do with your life. Dear
Dr Sharp I believe you who knew the law was unjust would not
mind if I say this so long after your death. I've done the best I could
with my life this book is for you.
Thank you for reading that dedication to your new book. When did you first speak
about your abortion. The
amazing thing was took me so long there was
no women's movement it was supposed to be a
secret women
didn't share in the same way. So it wasn't until many
years later after New York magazine had started and I had gone
to cover an abortion speak out held in a in a
church downtown in New York
City and suddenly I heard other women standing up and talking
about what it was like to have to go out and seek an illegal abortion this was actually
an
alternate hearing to one that the New York State legislature was holding on
the liberalization of abortion law in New York State this was before the Supreme
Court ruling and you know a group of early feminists I
just say said wait a minute you know in New
York. In the legislature they asked fourteen men and one nun to testify.
You can't make this up.
Let's
let let's hear from women who have actually had this experience. So I sat there
as a reporter for New York magazine listening to women
tell their stories you know that were tragic
and ludicrous and every human emotion
all wrapped into one and suddenly I thought wait a minute you
know I had an abortion and actually one in three American
women had needed an abortion at some time in her life so why
is
this illegal and why is it dangerous and it's the kind
of revelation that comes from people just telling the truth
and discovering you're not
alone. Do you often wonder what your life would have been like had you
not had the abortion and had you had a child at that age.
You know it just you know I don't know what would have happened I had been
doing all of the foolish things that we then did like riding
horseback throwing ourselves down stairs. You know. All kinds of things in the
hope let it stop you right there did you throw yourself
downstairs Yeah I kind of I did. I did and I you know I am the most.
Cowardly person you can imagine so physically speaking but I did
I kept thinking that
somehow you know I could I don't know what I thought I
was desperate I really was desperate because you know I just knew
that if
I went home and married which I would have had to do.
It would be to the wrong person it would be to a life that wasn't mine.
That wasn't mine at
all so what surprises you about the
current debate around abortion. I
think I am still most surprised by the inability
or the reluctance of many people to tell the truth because.
You know
about the need for abortion and I must say about the morality of abortion because
it seems to me
that every child has the right to be born loved and
wanted and every person has the right to control male
and female to control their own bodies from this from the
skin. I think we we need a legal principle called something
like bodily integrity which recognizes that the State
me. Jael us they can't insist on injections
or tests or pressuring us for organ transplants or. You know
that our skin needs to. Be the the line of defense
between
our own dignity and will and any
outside force we do need a new wave of telling the truth I think however I'm
not surprised by the opposition
because it is the basis.
Of everything I mean to be able the definition of patriarchy is to be able
to
control reproduction and that means you have to control women's
bodies. You spent half of your life on the road you're still on the road a lot.
You grew up on the road. Let's talk a little bit about your very atypical
childhood your mother was often incapacitated by depression
chemical depression.
You know. I don't know what to call I think her spirit was broken. You know
she before I was born I had to give up everything she loved and
cared about and she was depressed she got addicted
to tranquilizers I just think her spirit was broken.
Your father until you were ten during the
summer ran a dance pavilion that he created. Would you
describe what your father did summers.
This was a little like and southern Michigan called Clark
like he had built a kind of
long big pier with part of it covered part of it
uncovered over the lake and on weekdays there would
be sort of canned music and a jukebox and on
weekends a band then the big bands of the thirty's and forty's used
to travel the country in the summertime in a bus and
so we would get some famous band sometimes Wayne King and Jovan nobody I
mean names I don't know if people know anymore. And this was his dream
and he you know he created a. Kind of magical place.
So what was it about being there were about being with your father
that procure Mother Spirit.
It just wasn't hers Well let me describe what she had been doing
before long before I was born she was a
pioneer newspaper reporter and journalist and actually editor
which was extraordinary. But it was an era in which she at first had to write under a
man's name in order to get published.
So you know she was a real pioneer and she loved it she adored
it at the same time she was married to my father a wonderful
kind charming utterly irresponsible man.
So there were always money troubles and you know lots of difficulties. She had my
sister who is nine years older than
me and I think you know She later explained she had fallen in love with a
man at work and had grown up believing that you could not divorce you
could not change. She had a girlfriend who wanted to come to
New York with her where she could try her hand at being a journalist you know she had all
these aspirations she just couldn't make it
work. She had what was then called a nervous breakdown which
meant she was in a senatorial for a year or two I'm not sure.
And there she got hooked on an early form of trying to realize
or so getting back to this life that you had as a child. Your mother
spirit was broken it was often hard for her to get out of bed. Your father created that
you know like wonderful dance to Billion summers. But then when the summer was
over the family would move into a van and drive
south and basically live when I say Van I should say trailer I suppose.
And then the family would live in the trailer for the duration until the
following summer you write that you never started out with enough money to complete the trip. Your
father would buy antiques and then sell them to antique. Dealers you know buy them at
country auctions and then sell them to antique dealers at higher prices to
fund your trip south. How did you like being itinerant like that.
I suppose the two things happened at once when you're a child one is that you just accept as
normal whatever's around you and the other is that you go to the movies and you
see kids or your classmates because I would go to school till it
got cold to hello in or something who are living a different way and you want to be like them you want
to be like the other kids.
It never for a moment occurred to me that they
might envy me so I both except as a and
hopes that my real parents would come find me and. Take me to a
house with a picket fence and a pony. I mean
that's the degree of of real ism and fantasy.
So you weren't in school for those years that your family was on the road. How did you learn to read
and do basic
math. Well I'm not sure I've ever learned to do basic
math but but I learned to
read just because my family had lots and lots of
books especially my mother you know read all the time my memory
is that I
learned how to read from ketchup bottles and labels and billboards along the highway.
I don't know I'm not sure but I don't remember not knowing how to read.
Was it legal for you to not be in school.
No I'm sure it was illegal and my mother always said that if the truth officer
showed up she would use her teaching certificate. The fact that it was for
university calculus which she had
been teaching in order to make money to finish college herself.
I don't know how impressive it would have been but anyway you know but no truant officer ever showed up.
Your parents separated when you were ten in one thousand nine hundred four and you had to take on a lot
of responsibility for your mother. In a drought with us some of the things you had to do for her when you were
still a child
yourself. Well it depended on you know on the ups and downs of her moods
but I would make her meals or the child's idea of a meal.
I kind of always worried about what I would find when I came home from school. You know because
she might be really depressed or she might have retreated into
another world
or she might be convinced that the war
was happening outside the house and
be wandering around in the street you know talking to other people
whose parents were say alcoholics and who also kind of didn't know what they
would find when they came home has made me realize that it's.
It's not.
I mean it's hopefully uncommon but it's certainly not unique my experience.
She was called the crazy lady of the neighborhood once you had a neighborhood. What
was your reaction to that and did it make you think of her differently than you did
before. You know I had I don't didn't make me think of
her differently she
was how can I say I mean she was a
loving wonderful woman who
were cited poetry by heart and was you know certainly
super loving toward me but sometimes she was just in another world and I didn't
know when that would
happen. Do you remember the moment when you first
realized women's rights was illegitimate issue. Along with all the
other rights that you were interested in fighting
for you know the amazing thing is how long it took me.
Actually I mean there there was no. At least to me there was no
visible women's movement. So I thought I just had
to function within the system as it
was and I Adana fied with everybody else who
was. Having a hard time I think women often do
that without knowing that it applied to us too but
I know it to the women who held that hearing on
abortion for
instance or you know who had been inside
the civil rights movement and the anti Vietnam movement and
even in those movements that
we utterly loved still were not treated
equally and so had understood that there needed to be and an
additional women's movement.
I remember you telling me that one of the reasons why you co-founded Ms Magazine was that writing
for other magazines they just weren't interested in women's issues they'd say Oh
we did an article about women's issues or about the women's liberation movement like
eight months ago so we don't need another article
yet and that article about men was like articles about the world but articles about
women fell into the category of like yeah we covered that a while ago. We're
done really well in that was true of women's magazines but
in other places where I was
writing including the Sunday New York Times you
know lots of other places they attitude was even worse it was sort of well if
we publish an article saying women are equal then in order to be objective we'll have to
publish
one saying they're not you know.
So whatever and just for that. Well it seemed perfectly logical to them
because they thought it was debatable if you see what I mean yeah I definitely it would be mean.
But it seemed extremely frustrating and outrageous to me.
Do you remember the articles the headlines in the first edition of MS I want to
see if those articles could still be written today. Like how much have things changed.
Well we did have. A piece about a couple that had. A
marriage contract in order to make up for the unequal laws on the books
they had made there their own
contract. We had reprinted a article from
another feminist publication called Why I want to wife by Judy cyphers
I remember she deserved a
member that I think
it was the woman talking about all the reasons why she needed to she needed a wife it
was funny
and wonder to have somebody at home was doing the cooking and cleaning and taking care of the errands and
stuff which were supposed to do but she was working so she needed somebody
to yeah and that role would have been right lol yeah so that first edition
was one hundred seventy two
right. Yes. What's your connection to Ms magazine now.
Now it's published by the Feminist Majority Foundation in Los
Angeles and I am an advisor to it
but not the daily role at all that I was
for you know such a very long
time and I'm very grateful to them that they are taking good care of it and
now its quarterly but it has a additional one big life on
the web.
If I ask you to make a list of the five most important issues for
women today what would be on that
list. Well I can do it but I would like
to say that it's the most important issues are those to women who are listening.
I mean it's not about dictating to each other what's important but
supporting each other and.
Solving the ones that are in our daily lives. I like however you just
mean if you if you add up you know in terms of the numbers of
people I would say. That competing
for number one would be violence against
females worldwide.
If you add up all the forms of violence whether it's domestic violence in this
country which is as enormously high high rate means the most
dangerous place for a woman in this country is that her own home and she's most likely to
be beaten or killed by some by a man she
knows or it is F.D.M. female genital
mutilation or it
is female infanticide or honor killings
or child
marriage and. Too early childbirth which is the major cause of death
among adolescent girls worldwide. So you know violence has reached.
An emergency of all it's I mean any violence is an emergency but you know this guy like
the
early MC has certainly increased with groups like the Taliban and ISIS.
Generally Italian women and denying them any form of
rights. Yes No it's. The extreme forms
of patriarchy often often religious so-called
religious and the violence against the males in war
zones sexualized violence in the Congo and. You know
many in the former Yugoslavia. You know and all of these
have mounted up to a real
emergency but tide. I would say for first
place is the ability of women
to decide when and whether to have children because that is a major cause
of death the the lack of that ability is a major cause of death and it is
also a major cause of inability to be
educated or to be free outside the home or to be healthy.
You know so I would say those two
concerns violence sexualized violence against women
and reproductive freedom or reproductive justice
are right up there in our focus in every country.
Gloria Steinem it has been great to talk with you again thank you so much. Thank you so
much Gloria Steinem recorded in October after the publication of her book
My Life on the road.